i've been going through the internet
looking for different pickup artists
because i've been obsessed ever since
we've gone through this
our fingers that's that's that's the
alpha show
i love that one uh well we have a new
one uh this gentleman
is a travel bum okay
so he's another sex tourist i'm i'm
getting a sex tourist vibe already he's
a sex tourist of course he is and
um again you're not none of this counts
when you go
like any of the things that you can't
get in america
if you can't get them in america then it
doesn't count there i could go
to eastern europe and live in a country
right now and drive a brand new mercedes
and have women carrying me around on
those so the old things the pharaohs
used to go on a flat
and wrestlemania and caesar's past
feeding me grapes
and i could live in a palace for like
500 a month
that doesn't make me cool i can't make a
youtube video and go
hey look at all you losers in l.a check
out my lifestyle and it's like
yeah but you're in minsk like there's no
you know what i mean like
or the video we watch with the black
dudes in cuba that would get buying sex
for t-shirts
exactly for that you're living in the
[ __ ] in the chernobyl non-exclusion
zone
and it's like well of course you're
living like a king out there there's
nobody there
well the title of this video is silent
pickup the greatest pickup of all time
is he just gonna stare at the girl the
whole time that would be great he just
sits there goes
she's like what are you doing
i'm gonna wheel you into [ __ ] me
the greatest pickup of all
about the greatest mic of all time
stop
[Music]
no way he just walked up to a girl and
did that it was in barcelona
and that's clearly not a woman who's
been hired for this
that's clearly not a one but mike that's
clearly not a high-end escort that they
hired for this video and also are we
even pretending that sam tripoli over
here could just pull this off like that
but like let's stop pretending no forget
the fact that he's
schlubby-looking if you're a really
good-looking young guy with a lot of
game and you just walk up to a [ __ ] and
do this
you're going to jail you can't do this
i never seen anything like this before
in my life
and i've seen you know a rapid
escalation and everything but i've never
seen this
never oh rapids so they okay so so the
pickup artist thing
researching this is great they have
terms
like different terms that they use rapid
escalation is one of them where you
you quickly like you work it so well
that you you know you go from just
talking to them to your finger banging
them in an alley
so that's what rapid escalation is oh
okay i was i always referred to that as
uh
sexual assault okay well different you
know different terms for different
people
really it's the thing that i know that
you know
okay i have to point something out and
bet you to notice this what's wrong with
his ear
and that's not cauliflower here because
cauliflower would be up here it's like
he has no
hole right it looks like an
ear on an action figure yeah right
does it not look like it looks exactly
like an ear
on like a wwe action figure
that'd be great if every video is in me
like hi i
uh couldn't help but notice you over
there and i wanted to come say hello
what's wrong with your ear dude go with
your man
i wonder how many videos are on the
editing room floor
of women just going dude what's up with
your [ __ ] ear
[Music]
how does sound get into it
it vibrates through it oh okay
yeah it's like you ever see like the um
like spiders or like flies have like
antennae
and the antenna actually um pick up
sounds polly sung says
he looks like the texture didn't load
right for his ear yeah
like an oblivion character a [ __ ]
cyberpunk like you put a bad mod in it
or something
well mike i always download the
realistic ears mod from nexus mods
maybe he's like the ear equivalent of
daredevil
um that's the the next level for any for
any coach out there
coach it's called
travelbumcoachcoaching.com
and who's [ __ ] this black guy because
he seems like a [ __ ]
nerd uh mike can you do me a favor and
go to travel bump coaching and just let
me know how much these packages cost
stupid coaching stop by curious what the
package cost
i'll play a little bit more while you
let me know next level of any coach
it's insane you do that it was just a
revelation for me
there's been a revelation being with
this man for some reason i thought
barcelona was going to give me
oh no it's still not loading oh it's
it's taking this long to load you know
what it is
too many people that's what it is
overloading the server
uh oh my gosh is it good first of all
took forever to load
so i'm thinking maybe it's like a lot of
stuff on the site but it's a wordpress
basic template site so that's no reason
it should be taken this long
uh let's see workshops oh he has
workshops
yeah he's got upcoming workshops what's
his next one
it's not the what's it's the where's
okay where's his next workshop
it's got such a basic
kiev prague and barcelona and odessa
so it's all these wait i'm sorry and
then odessa it's all these
it's all these like eastern european
like just
hell holes where they where the exchange
rate is outrageous
i i love these video like you know i
like bald and bankrupt because he does
like
he does the whole travel around and do
it on a budget thing and
show you but like all his videos are
like i'm going to show you cool stuff
check out this old soviet statue i'm
going to eat borsch
in a [ __ ] cafe and some [ __ ] like
his shit's cool because you're like oh
this is a real travel blog
but like these the and he has a hot
chick girlfriend that's like [ __ ]
outrageously hot for him but like but
it's the same girlfriend it's been
around for years
these guys literally just travel and go
i will give you money for sex and then
they go on
youtube and they go bro look at all this
[ __ ] i'm pulling
it's unbelievably [ __ ] scummy
and you notice something about this he's
trying to look as is like
cool as handsome as possible in this
like with the faraway
he looks like an album cover yeah yeah
he's really he looks like every
honestly he looks like every edm album
cover
from like 2010 to 2015.
every like every calvin harris-esque
artist
did this uh uh who was the one that died
zayn
or whatever no no zane stole up there's
one guy that died
uh but all these edm djs had
album covers like this for like five
years straight when they were like
avicii yeah thinking of each other yeah
i'm sure i think
that avicii that is the one that died
but like they all had those like yeah
bro like
like i want to get a shot of me but like
not during the party right
i want like after the party you know
when i'm like looking really somber
you know and we're gonna call the album
after the party
volume two no the after party no
in it in parentheses to afterparty
amazing woman this time but i feel like
it gave me you
in a way that it gave me you it's very
gay sounding
it uh allowed me to see these insights
because i don't
i'm more attractive now than i've ever
been and it's because oh
good news royce i found how much it's
got how much is it it's probably cheap
travel bum coaching it's a 13-day
workshop
to two weeks two weeks three to four
hours per day plus extra activities a
zen meditation retreat oh thank god uh
non-duality i don't know what that means
well that means no dualities i'll
[ __ ] kill you
private shadow work oh i guess they
follow you
and you imagine you're hitting on a girl
there's a guy right behind you going
like
is this yeah what are you training to be
a waiter
hi this is royce he'll be training with
us today i'm just here to help
tell him remember to tell him about the
soups
we have that new soup make sure you tell
them
it's it is oh you didn't ask me how much
rice oh how much mike
does anyone have do you want to take
guesses does anyone have
three hundred dollars laying around not
on me i don't have it on me
sixty three hundred dollars sixty three
hundred does that include [ __ ]
airfare in a hotel and i would feel so
big because you know this guy's not
pulling
large groups no he has
fourteen thousands so this guy imagine
being like
because nobody i guarantee you he's not
no customers but
imagine being like the one nerd that
pays 63 by the way p
pay 6300 and then you have to fly to
odessa
so imagine getting to odessa which by
the way would be funny if it was just
odessa florida
oh odessa texas um
but then you get imagine going there
right and you paid the 6300 and you fly
which
that's another like [ __ ] 1200 of
flying all over you get to about that so
you get you out you do all this right
and then you show up and realize you're
like the only guy there
imagine the feeling of knowing like well
that's the black guy i guarantee you
that's what happened to him oh he's one
of the marks yeah cause he's the one
he's the one that said oh you changed my
life and stuff
these insights because i don't i'm more
attractive now than i've ever been
how bad how [ __ ] up were you before
you must have been a [ __ ] mess
stephan arkell
he put him in that machine where urkel
turned cool that's right yeah
it just turned his white tank top into a
black tank top
that's all it did that's it that's all
it'll be a practice for me
for life the greatest oh my god pickup
of all time what does that even mean
the greatest pickup by the way does
anybody fall for
that anymore like do women still fall
for the
the negging and stuff not the nagging
but like the fake sincere guy oh yeah
the guy that like talks like this and
like does like the really really robotic
brushing the hair out of the air like
the soft tones and the
like eye contact and the thing like all
these
gimmicks that these guys have come up
with do women fall for that [ __ ] because
like
i know in movies it happens but like you
know
the like the guy will run off like the
chick would run off with some zen dude
who's like cartoonishly weird but like
the guy's always like they always cast
like a matthew mcconaughey
where at least it makes sense like an
idris hello where you're like
well she's probably just gonna go [ __ ]
that guy but these guys do it and these
guys are just
average joes that are like i want you to
i want you to really like look me in my
eyes as we get
set like like does anybody buy that [ __ ]
this looks like crowder i'm going to
you change my mind
[Laughter]
because you've seen everything right
you've seen
every kind of approach i'm sorry can you
speak up
this is what i mean though this is what
they do like because they'll tell you
like it's part of the program and you
talk like this it's in a non-threatening
like women women love when you talk like
no women don't what
women do not enjoy having to go what can
you speak up huh
are you mumbling you've seen
every kind of pickup line every kind of
story memorized to impress a girl but
if there were such a thing as the
greatest pickup of all time
wouldn't it have to be something totally
other
a totally different language and physics
of what we're used to
what with no technique would have to be
something universal
something oh this dude's into [ __ ]
crystals i can already
tell you yeah well it's part note but
it's but he's not even probably into it
it's just part of his gimmick
like i guarantee he probably lives it so
that
it seems real but this is all part of
his gimmick zen guy
underlying the way that we speak
something underlying the way that we
interact
something timeless and where would you
start
for such a thing where would you start
a silent pickup here we go here it is
i already scrolled through the comments
and there's a lot of people saying like
this is totally staged
it's absolutely staged
who's watching this video and going
that's totally real
can you imagine what but let's say it
was real but let's let's play in this
make-believe world
walking up to a woman and going stop
well yeah
i mean i could have not if i was trying
to not if i was courting them
i could imagine doing that to just be
obnoxious to some woman
um but this is why i said in the
beginning i already knew where this was
going when they showed this
even if you're [ __ ] gorgeous even if
you're an adonis
walking around with abs and just looking
like a young brad pit
and you go up to a girl and do that
they're going to scream
and call the police like you can't go up
to a chick and touch her
face who you don't know
stop
this is the best
she's also clearly a hooker
yeah she's clearly a high-end hooker
that he hired was like just being on my
youtube video
this is the best he would people would
never know what this means
this wouldn't work and any no for no guy
would this work
this wouldn't work for a famous guy
this wouldn't work for [ __ ] dude this
wouldn't work for the like
who's who's like a famous guy now that
chick's like i don't even watch it jason
mamoa
this wouldn't do if jason momoa did this
you know what the girl would do the girl
would go home and be talking to her
girlfriends and she'd go you know
weirdest [ __ ] thing happened to me
today jason momoa walked up to me
he's a [ __ ] weirdo you're right
i'm intentionally mirroring her body
language
standing to the side what would happen
is they would walk around you and keep
walking yeah they would
go don't ever touch me again who are you
now i face her taking her hand
increasing emotional impact
my intent an expression
i'm sorry can we see the [ __ ]
comments on this
sure uh
i'm quite skeptical about this it
doesn't look realistic bra that was bs
people believe in this stuff in the car
okay good good good good um like what
the [ __ ] y'all been walking up the
chicks and suddenly staring at them
this got to be fake or like a paid actor
i don't know if women are different in
barcelona but if you try this in the u.s
you'll be absolutely a stalking creepy
weirdo
i dude nobody's okay good good nobody's
buying this
cause like sometimes i'll look at the
comments
and it breaks my heart like i'm sure
you've had the same thing where you read
the comments and you go oh my god why
are people falling for this but
this kind of uh makes me feel better to
see so many people going that's [ __ ]
i'm still trying to figure out what
hippie damblitarian is talking about
it's going way over my head and i'm a
pretty intelligent dude
uh nothing matters uh nothing matters
because no
nothing it's okay whatever that doesn't
matter um
you just hypnotize her how much was bail
for the assault charge she made up the
next morning
would have been would have
would have been quite how she reacted to
a loud stinky fart at some point maybe
mirroring that as well
okay
what thoughts do you think i'm having
was it worth paying her three thousand
dollars to do this like that's a thought
i'd be having
yeah that's this is so [ __ ] fake man
what thoughts do you need to account for
like and again i look i've done
some wild [ __ ] that has gotten girls to
be initially interested
right that i'm telling you that wouldn't
there's no
scenario where that could work and i've
even told people you know with the old
patrice theory where it's like you're
better off just making a girl hate your
guts
yeah right off the jump because you can
work from that you can work back from
that
if they're indifferent to you you're
[ __ ] so like
even just being argumentative like i
picked a chick up in tampa a few years
ago
by literally making fun of her from the
time she started talking to me
but not like you know you fat [ __ ] but
just in a way where she was like oh
you're watching the game and i'm like
you watch
baseball who the [ __ ] watches baseball
and i started breaking her balls about
how stupid baseball is
and then it gave you oh what i like to
tear but and you're like yeah you're a
[ __ ] idiot
and you have a little fun and by then i
ended up [ __ ] a chick that night
but like if i just walked up to a girl
and i was like
like i would have been arrested that it
would have been jailed
like you're going to jail you can't like
especially if they had you
on a um camera doing that like you you
could
you could technically probably go to
jail for some [ __ ] like that
if they had you on camera like touching
some girl's face and the girl's like i
don't know this man he's grabbing me the
cops might be like dude
listen i don't want to see you around
here for the rest of the night if i do
i'm going to arrest you on some [ __ ]
i still
prefer they arrest your friend that does
street magic to them but that's fine
it's to be safe from judgment
and her sense of being judged this guy
is trying to do the [ __ ]
yogi uh crystal meditation [ __ ]
wow he's really relaxing her with that
stare
why isn't this awkward
this is the best
here i could feel she was she softened
so now i soften
and show my vulnerability the little boy
and me to meet and play with the little
this is
insane this is insane the little boy and
me to meet and play with the little girl
in her what
it's not only is he full of [ __ ] and
this whole thing staged
but the way he's like filling it in is
just
even creepier by the way somebody in the
chat
does have a good point and i do want to
uh
somebody in the chat wrote you guys are
just mad you don't crush puss like this
guy he's right well you're right
it's it's fair
what do they play in odessa and kiev
honestly soccer uh we just sort of sadly
kick this old
deflated soccer ball around and cry
i'm actually mirroring her but with more
than just my posture right now
no way nobody's gonna hold him and now
my posture is intentionally more
elevated than her
so what i don't get is right does the
black guy
no it's staged or because i have a
feeling this guy's the type
actually that's what i'm saying i think
this guy's the type that would make the
effort to convince this black guy to
keep giving him money
maybe he would keep the magic going he
probably arranged this
and then told the black guy like you
know watch this and
like i guarantee he's not in on it at
all he's buying strength and confidence
that's not true you just need an open
heart and proper non-duality mirror
training
all you need is non-duality mirror
training look man i don't know how many
times you just make up
like i would say i really wish i had no
soul
because emulating these guys and
applying it and making
a [ __ ] load of money would be so easy
but it's just so scummy right like it's
it's like televangelism and pickup
artists there's so many like
things that i just look at i'm like this
is too gross
non-duality celebrate emotionally
physically and mentally
using non-duality mirror pairing you can
see
i'm now a world would make no sense
safe and open canvas to her to resolve
the creative pressure
she needs to paint to create and get
closer to the canvas
what just wonder where you came from
he's still not talking i love this oh
the chat says
you want to go to a country that still
has outbreaks of polio and leprosy
that's what you get that's where you get
chicks bro
cause they can't because they really
just want somebody who has
a couple of bucks for food
he did the eyelash thing he did the
eyelash he did the eyelash thing it's
totally fake i know this is 100 fake
it's so ridiculous
oh my god puzzle box that's a good point
why is she mic'd up
because he's my but his mic wouldn't
pick up her because lapel mics
very limited range
this is so fake
by the way she's 100 a hooker look at
her you can learn to do this with anyone
and she also and she also doesn't
realize that she's being filmed
that woman is a hooker
it's not hypnosis but it is transporting
[Laughter]
man this is incredible oh my god this is
where are you feeling embarrassed are
you feeling embarrassed i'm feeling
embarrassed for the black guy because
yeah he's he's definitely not in on it
he was not around when this guy was
making arrangements
oh man this is incredible
she likes my bold willingness to feel
see women like a man who's unafraid to
express it and also pause
a woman like i'm just going to tell you
this right now a woman like this
in a country like this who's dressed
like that who looks like that
also wouldn't react this this positively
to this kind of a scenario um
in real life because there there is
certain people have a look to them of
somebody that
has [ __ ] to do they're on their way to
go do some [ __ ]
this woman is dressed like a person who
who would be like i'm
going somewhere like a person like that
doesn't have time to be
sitting around letting some [ __ ]
greasy stranger in a tank top touch
their face
like nobody was dressed like that if you
saw a woman like that in new york city
if you asked her hey excuse me do you
have the time they'd tell you to go [ __ ]
yourself
go find a clock you [ __ ] loser you
don't have a phone [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] your dick excuse me do you
have the time
[ __ ] off whoa hey jesus christ
see women like a man who's unafraid to
express himself
you know you could turn it the other way
around and say this is normal
what is everything else yeah man like
this is normal dude everything else is
nice
[ __ ] damn i would really legitimately
feel bad
taking money from people right who
who are so hopeless like people who i
know for a fact like i'm never gonna
be able to help you right like like if
you said like
if you had a bunch of like weird artists
like that black guy that were like
hey can can you help me get
um a girlfriend if i pay you like
there's scenarios in life that a normal
human being should feel like
nah man i can't i'll try to help you a
little bit for free because you do seem
like you need some help but like
to start these programs when you know
that
it's never gonna make these guys lives
better
you're doing this you're doing these
fake things to try to hustle them it's a
grift like
this makes me angry when i see this [ __ ]
dude
their way around and say this is normal
what is everything else
and that's a good point somebody says oh
lucky for him he also found a person in
barcelona who speaks english
maybe all these people are just
creations
in our theater oh i hate this hold on
hey hey hey
relax you're never gonna get [ __ ] bro
just give it up
but what if all these people give it up
no hold on give it up black guy you're
going to be the only black guy to live
and die without ever getting [ __ ]
you're going to be the only one what if
what if like
the universe like isn't real dude like
what if it was just
the black guy is going to live and die
having had more [ __ ] than this guy
and that's a fact they exist
how do you agree
what i'm about to do now is the holy
grail of seduction
you ready you ready are you ready for
the holy grail today
are you going to sing holy grail because
that would be dope no
justin timberlake parts no he just
drinks out of the dirty one because
jesus was a common hand
yeah i hope i have this yes seriously i
hope this guy [ __ ] drinks out of the
wrong hole turns to a skeleton [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hope he opens up the ark of the covenant
i'm out of my head or thoughts
just enough to read and then mirror her
heart in a space i've created where she
feels comfortable
skipping weeks maybe even years of
getting to know someone
wow the dalai lama said man the dalai
lama said what
oh the black guys say man it's just
genius
i've never met anyone who to me is a
stranger
if you can see that you're not separate
from others you can naturally guide them
to feel that they are not separate from
you
you want to try to get this guy on the
show i'd love to talk to him as the
dalai lama once said
stall him for a few minutes i have to
take a [ __ ] did he say that
probably at some point i'm sure he said
that at least he's been on a lot of tv
shows right
i'm sure one time i'm sure he found a
nicer way to say it
yeah let's get them all let's try to get
this guy on as mahatma gandhi once said
ew no blacks just write this guy and go
hey man look we're we're two
fat losers who don't ever crush puss oh
that'd be great
and we'll promote you we'll promote you
on our show yeah oh that'd be great
we'll get him on
i would like to do that and promote a
stiff and kiev
fast tracking the heart i can lead where
the heart already wants to go
it wants to go home by the way i just
want to say i'm a big fan of your
program and i was watching some of your
videos and i took some of your advice
and uh it helped me out a lot like you
taught me that if i hire a prostitute
that i can pick them up any way i want
they don't care
it's amazing they even let you do butt
stuff if you bam it off
honestly i mean you you paid a [ __ ] and
you just walk up and go
hey did you like ducktales growing up
and
you they'll be like my [ __ ] is so wet
[Laughter]
so what does a woman want
it's funny because to provide what a
woman wants beyond the intellect
beyond being a man beyond your idea of
being control that you think seduction
is all about
your language you might find you have to
do less with our nervous thinking minds
i hate this man but less is hard to do
look we don't have enough time but next
maybe maybe some point this week maybe
not tomorrow
they actually has video of one of his
workshops
day game infield it's him and it's him
and that's good i bet he have workshop
part one
and it's him going with the guy and
training him
so the guy has like a headset in
and he's training him to pick people up
oh god okay
we'll we'll do this one we'll do this
one this week we have to
it looks too good look we have to stop
here
it's a silent pickup obviously it works
every single time and i recommend that
every
man does this i mean honestly like i i
really
genuinely get angry like at these guys
like i feel bad because
for the same way i used to get mad at
televangelists and i know some people go
oh well [ __ ] those if they're going to
give money to jerry falwell [ __ ] them
they deserve to have their money taken
and i understand that that
that sort of mentality about it but at
the same time like
it doesn't make the people who take
advantage of stupid people
any less scummy well you're preying on
them like jerry following is a great
example like they're putting on old
people who have
a dying spouse or who have nothing left
and you know
these people are decent men these are
men who
who who really maybe they're on the
spectrum which really don't know how to
communicate not just with women but in
general
so desperate like any young guy would be
like
you know look i we all had our you know
our ups and downs i think if you're not
completely socially you know it doesn't
matter even if you're fat or if you're
ugly or if you don't whatever don't have
a lot of money
normal guys can go out there and pull
something
in their lifetime it just will happen
from you being out and being socialized
but like to to try to like
to know like how important especially
when you were in your early 20s like
how important getting laid was how
important was getting laid but it was
it was a pretty important thing was to
get laid when you were young
and um to know that
and then to like these young guys are
just desperate to get laid and
they just want some affection and you're
like i got this
i will fix this for you if you follow my
6 300
workshop which is just because you know
that guy also these guys are not
making a lot of money because if they
were making a lot of money
they would already have solved this
problem so these are guys that probably
don't have a lot of money and are giving
up thousands of dollars to learn
tricks that don't work based off videos
that were staged it's really [ __ ] up